[Music]
could idris elba be the next bond the
actor attended the same party with his
wife sabrina following the premiere
sparking rumors that he could be the
front runner
oh but there's another contender to fill
007 shoes tom hardy miss moneypenny
herself naomi harris told our matt cohen
she's all in on that idea
[Music]
oh my gosh i'm down for that i'm gonna
vote for that seriously
he would be amazing
amazing
what's your take on that i don't think
i'm talking about that
well we know tom can play a spy remember
when he was a cia agent and this means
war with reese and chris you've never
killed anybody with your bare hands not
this week but right now tom starring in
marvel's new movie venom let there be
carnage in theaters friday he's
reprising his role as eddie brock the
mild-mannered reporter inhabited by the
alien entity venom
you have got to get control of your
aggression
i think he's noble's soul and it but i
just think he's come to a certain
you know path where venom appears
and it's horrendous
woody harrelson returns to the franchise
franchise's venom's ultimate adversary
carnage naomi is his love interest
street people love serial killers why is
it fun to play the bad guy i don't know
it's a far cry from his role in hunger
games which is about to hit a milestone
10 years since its release
[Laughter]
time i think i'm just
so old something comes along to remind
me no you're older than you think you
are
jennifer lawrence is about to be a mama
how incredible is that that's
unbelievable that's just why
you